all right so our next speaker
uh was was on the list she's the head
peo of uh us Socom Science and
Technology but also little known fact
she's also a second deegree black belt
in Taekwondo don't mess with her Miss
Lisa Sanders she would take you out how
many people in here know that US Special
Operations Command actually can buy
things raise your hand Okay so not
everybody that's Les one thing you'll
have learned today is that US Special
Operations Command can buy things so
that's a that's a good thing to know how
many of you in here are what you would
consider an entrepreneur startup you
know Tech Discovery element raise your
hand okay um how many in in here have
done business with the government before
okay much higher number than I thought
would be all right so with that um I
have one of the best jobs in the
Department of Defense I although I do
have to say I really enjoyed hearing
Brett's talk because I have lived that
Journey um I've got a really unusual
career um as well yep it is moving
through here so we may be moving back
and forth here we'll we'll go from there
all right I'm gonna go back here for a
second so just is there an up Buton back
back arrow there we go all right um so I
answered an ad in the newspaper to go to
work for the Navy in
1987 um which everybody looks at me and
goes really nobody ever does that well
that was the way my career started uh
and then I switched back and forth
between engineering and program
management a couple of times never worn
a uniform always supported the military
as a civilian uh went through a base
closure grew up in Indianapolis started
my career in Indianapolis and then moved
to pent River Maryland where I then came
to support Special Operations Command um
converting a marine v22 aircraft which
is the one with the Hy tilt rotors uh
for uh to be used for Special Operations
Command it is the first fully functional
test airplane and it is in the museum at
right Pat in Dayton so I'm super proud
of that and in 2010 I actually took a um
practice interview to go in to be the
deputy of Science and Technology and lo
and behold they called and offered me
the job Color Me shocked and uh I've
essentially been there since then so
what I am going to talk to you all about
is very different from most of what
y'all heard today um I'm really going to
talk to you about how do you do business
with Special Operations Command so with
that what is our mission what do we do
within Special Operations Command
Science and Technology I'm trying to be
super sensitive of the acronyms because
I learned a whole bunch of new acronyms
today that I had never heard of so uh
and and Military speak can be
particularly bad I will not read my
slides to you you all are adults the
thing to be aware of is that our
portfolio is everything in the discovery
and development domain to support
anything that special operations forces
would need to achieve their objectives
all right so what makes us unique what
is the Special Operations unique
requirements there it is really about
that's that special operations peculiar
part if you ever do business with us one
of the things people will tell you is
thanks for your idea but that's not soft
unique that is uh so what does that mean
it really is getting after asymmetric
advantage that the big services are not
doing um so there are a few missions
that are specifically designated to
Special Operations but we can also do
things that enable us to do those things
that the services aren't providing for
us big changes the asymmetric advantage
and then across the full run realm of
and spectrum of conflict yes welcome to
Florida it's afternoon and it's raining
um so most people when they think of
Special Operations Command think of odar
30 they think of kicking bad guys
jumping out of airplanes you know all of
that thing we do much more than that and
especially in the world as it is today
as we're in a postwar on terror um
doesn't mean that terrorism doesn't
exist and Special Operations still has
the mission for counterterrorism but we
are also going back to the longstanding
role of develop help in Partners to
prevent preclude and predict major
conflict to deter delay major conflict
those are all things that special
operations forces is uniquely able to do
by with and through our partners all
right so way too much talking more
action right so what does that look like
you know that's a lot of generalized
language okay great this is motherhood
apple pie you're really going to get to
the meat this is my meat and and I am
going to start with the center there
lots and by the way all of this material
is going to be available to you part of
the reason that this material is here is
so that when you go back and go okay
what were those areas or where does that
go you'll have that the last thing on
here is a set of websites and email
addresses so that you can have them so I
start this section of the brief and
several people have said there briefings
are an hour long normally I can do this
slide in 30 minutes or 3 minutes so
you're getting the three minute version
actually this will probably be the
six-minute version the three minute part
is in the middle what does Special
Operations Science and Technology care
about it is the center um Circle if you
start with the presumption that
everything Special Operations does is
centered around the operator which is
the first Special Operations truth is
that humans are more important than
Hardware you start with that so the
first thing that we focus on and these
are called capability Focus areas an
acronym that doesn't matter um is
biotechnologies and Human Performance so
what do I need to get give the operator
in order for them to do their
job they may need medical care we do a
lot of austere combat casualty care um
things like freeze-dried plasma
historically in the past spe our troops
because they go out separate and way far
away from a lot of people there were
times that you could or could not take a
person on a mission if they had the
wrong blood type because we transfuse
blood across the team so if if you had
an operator that didn't have a matched
blood type they might not go on a
mission now we have developed a a plasma
that is freeze dried that you can add
water to and so we're able to take those
operators giving us greater capability
to do our mission so there's everything
from that through how do I get them
prepared and not get injured
beforehand how do I get the right mix of
nutrition how do I get the right mix of
physical training how do I predict if
the next jump out of that airplane
they're going to tear their ACL all
right so we're doing Human Performance
activities and then how does the human
interface with with their system that's
our human portfolio so the human has to
be the center of everything we do but in
order to do that they need to understand
their environment so the the the next
tick on that clock is situational
awareness and and um uh what's
historically been called for us a great
acronym intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance but what does that look
like in a world where it is global and
we're about integrated deterrence and we
don't have full access to all of that
information all of the data that you all
have been talking about very much is a
part of okay we'll see if this comes
back up again I may just talk there we
go uh of Next Generation situational
awareness so the human needs to
understand their environment and in
order to understand that environment
they need need to get information in and
give information out and process that
and turn that into meaningful decision
quality uh uh uh information so the the
next tick down if you get down to about
the five o'clock is um networking data
management so that includes all of the
range of communications across the
electromagnetic spectrum it also
includes the processing of that
information because we can't say Hey
Siri and go back to the cloud all right
so we need Ed level processing we also
need analytic tools to be able to apply
that information in a tactically
relevant environment we were talking a
little bit earlier about you know if you
make the wrong decision on Advertising
data um somebody just gets an ad that
they didn't want all right or you may
you may miss a marketing opportunity to
sell some tickets if we make the wrong
decision on da data sometimes the
consequences are pretty high so that
networking data management is really
really important it is a big area of
interest for us but in order to so now
you've got the human
understanding their environment passing
sharing processing information some
place or time so our next area is
mobility and placement and access and
that historically has meant jumping out
of airplanes taking undersea platforms
to get to places but imp placement and
access in the world of the future and
integrated deterrence may be a virtual
presence it may be working in the Cyber
domain and being able to have access to
either gain information or have an an
effect which which is our next area
because we need to again reiterate the
human understands their environment
shares information and processes
information someplace somewhere in order
to have an effect because we don't do it
just for nothing and sometimes that
effect is non-kinetic it is knowledge it
is sharing information with a partner
sometimes it is a kinetic effect it may
be using information to change
somebody's mind it may may be jamming
somebody's Discovery you know their
sensor so that is much much different
than a guy wearing camouflage
parachuting out and shooting a bad guy
but you can still see how a guy can
parachute out and shoot a bad guy in
this in this pathway any questions about
those areas you can you can drive a
truck through all of those okay it is
everything from submarines to satellite
Lights Body armored to radios You Name
It We Do it all right that's the
important part to be aware of how do so
so with that much with the boiling the
ocean how do we do
that we um we do look at strategic
guidance up in the upper um corner of
this is senior and there's acronym soup
here it is spelled out down below but
the Department of Defense has a national
defense strategy within the national
defense strategy it says Special
Operations Command is assigned to do X
whatever that X thing is that is
something we consider all right the
commander us Socom has a vision and that
is tied into our S&T Vision so we use
that strategic guidance in order to help
us gain an understanding of what's
important to us we also go from the
bottom up we have connection with our
user communities all the way down to you
know the E4 that's on a Seal Team all
the way through our component commanders
we have each of their services Army Navy
Air Force Marines all have units that do
Special Operations they all give us
bottom up feedback I'm s& there are
programs official programs in the
Department of Defense that are managed
out of Special Operations Command they
have road maps and there are gaps in
their future road maps that they feed me
as hey I need as an example uh about
eight to 10 years ago we knew we needed
to get back into the undersea domain and
the power and energy for submarines for
the seal Mission weren't capable of of
meeting their objectives so we invested
in that portfolio in order to meet a
tech insertion road map so that is the
top and the bottom those are the
mechanisms that we do that we develop we
bring it through our transition Partners
sometimes that's soft unique and goes
into our programs of record sometimes we
give it to a uh Army and Navy and Air
Force to buy for us and they feed it
back to our users then we also go out
and experiment with those
Technologies the last thing I want to
talk about and I'll talk about a lot
more in the next few slid is this left
side of the bubble because if I knew
everything that would be great I'd be
omniscient and I'd be able to figure out
exactly which projects I should do and I
would deliver capability and it' be
awesome but there's an awful lot that we
don't know and so we have this left side
B diagram is how do we know learn what
we don't know what's being done in the
technology field what we should be doing
that nobody's thought about yet those
are all things that I'm going to talk
about just in a minute all right this is
just a little more detail for your
reference on those different Focus areas
that I talked about there's an examplar
picture of an active program that we
have in each of these domains and for
your info we run about 60 to 70 programs
at any given time spend about $200
million a year all right so one of those
vend diagrams that fed the process was
our technology enablers um it was one of
the circles that I showed there and so
um I had a great conversation with these
folks about our innovation cycle and I
don't have time to go through all of it
but if you go to the softworks dorg web
page sof
werx and it's there's a link on the back
here that you can see um you will see
the topics that we do think of that as
Discovery that's truly Discovery we take
a soft specific problem space how do I
do auster partner Communications in an
Arctic environment in
2035 and we did that in partnership with
Norway so you write ask a very general
enal question you get a bunch of people
that don't normally do business with us
in a room along with a bunch of our
users and you brainstorm and you come
out of there with Concepts then you take
a few of those Concepts and you say okay
let's say that I'm trying to do how do I
do Warfare in a loral which is near the
coastline you're at sea but you're near
the coastline uh environment when I
don't have access to it what if I stuck
a laser on a shark and I okay great now
the next state so that's your concept
okay I mean this this is not you know a
beautiful thing that you can go buy here
go buy this thing right it's a concept
then the next stage would be I want to
stick a laser on a shark what kind of
laser how how how do I control the shark
how deep does it have to dive how long
does it have to last you de and you
deconstruct the systems engineering
problem and you say okay what's the
state of the market what's the state of
the shelf so that's stage two of that
process stage three of that process says
here's something that I need to explore
if it's feasible and we do technology
Sprints to demonstrate that concept so
that's The Foundry method methodology
anybody here been to a technical
experimentation I do know that a couple
of you have anybody else nobody else has
if you don't do anything else from this
today first of all you learned that you
can buy that Socom buy can buy things
and the second thing is how do you
figure out what Socom wants to buy
there's a page called doing business
with Socom and if you go to that it will
give you the link
to go to our experimentation domain so
if you have a thing you can touch and
feel not a concept but a thing okay and
that thing can be a piece of software
right but it's something that's at a
prototype level we bring it into the
hands of the operator in a relevant
operational environment so this isn't
sitting in a lab by the way if it
doesn't work without air conditioning or
nice clean power it's probably not a
good thing to take out here because we
don't get nice clean power it's dirty it
rains it's hot but we'll give you
feedback on how your product might might
meet Special Operations needs so there
are users there are program managers at
that experimentation event we do at
least three a year usually we try to hit
at least one over at Avon Park uh we did
one for instance with our biomed
portfolio at the camels lab downtown so
medical simulation uh which was a really
good pro project that we did with them
so technical experimentation helps us to
understand what the state of the Shelf
is uh oh casy got it unlocked for me all
right so and then the last thing that we
had on there was our strategic
engagement which is our work with
academics um with universities with
government Laboratories we do work with
the big big brains at Department of
energy and and the Department of Defense
Laboratories Etc um we have a
partnership with University of South
Florida's applied engineering Institute
or in Institute of Applied engineering I
never get that straight um and um I
already mentioned Norway but we have
representatives from Canada UK Australia
Sweden and New Zealand as well as Norway
sitting in in our spaces so lots of
international Partnerships all right
this timeline I'm not reading through
all this I mentioned Futures Innovation
Foundry and experimentation events some
people ask me what's the difference
between the two I think I've did a
pretty good job of concept versus things
you can touch and feel and you want to
put in a field environment this is a
schedule for the next year of what we
have planned for those events again
you'll have copies of them not intended
to read it to you all right and I
mentioned and promised to you that I
would give you the link
and the ways that you can contact us
that's what this is for each of the
areas we've got
futures um I did not talk at all about
small business Innovative technology
research program how many of you care
about sbir know what it is want to have
information about it okay those of you
that didn't raise your hand if you think
you have something that could support
the government and most of you that are
industry in here said you were
entrepreneurs startups you should care
most of of you that don't care probably
don't care because you're like I don't
want to wait for 10 years to get
$100,000 it's really not worth my time
um because that can be one of the pro or
I need a path to transition not just a
million and a half dollars to give you a
report which tends to be a lot of the um
the baggage that comes with sbir us
Socom has special Authority in law that
we got put in law I'm super proud of
this it's the first time I know anybody
that's put law in place um and we work
through our partner intermediary
softworks to enable a businesso business
Award of small business Innovative
research funds for the purposes of
delivering disruptive capability to our
war Fighters here are our two objectives
for this program number one give these
contracts to businesses that don't do
business with the government okay the
second one and in order to do that we
have to be in your Innovation cycle time
so we will deliver those capabilities to
a production decision and award within
two years or less we've been doing this
since March
2020 I think I'm going to mess up these
numbers I want to say we've awarded 75
contracts phase ones phase twos 50% of
eligible phase twos have awarded phase
three
contracts average award time is 16
months to production decision
fastest is 11 we have not broken two
years on anything we've done it's all
been less than two years so if you're
interested in that um we do that through
softw works you can go to that same
doing you know Socom web page and softw
works web page and they will give you
the topics that is the end of my
prepared pitch I'm the last thing
between you and the end of the day I am
open to questions so if anybody has
questions